Bitte schön.
Danke.
Okay.
Ja, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Aydin. Ich bin hier als Sintetik und heute türse so ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ja.
Ich würde so erst ein paar Fragen so irrer personen stellen.
Wie bitte?
Wie heißt es?
Ich möchte Anna Lena Nosbusch.
Anna Lena.
Anna Lena ist ein Wort.
Anna und Lena. Anna Lena.
Ja.
Nosbusch.
Könnten Sie Ihren Nachnamen bestellen?
Ja.
Nosbusch, großes N.
Dann O, S, B,
S, C, H.
Okay.
Frau Nosbusch.
Ja.
Wie heißt es Sie?
29.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,73 m groß und wiege 64 kg.
74 kg.
64.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Frau Nosbusch.
Was fühlst du uns? Was haben Sie beschweren?
Ja, ich habe seit zwei Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden immer schlimmer.
Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie Schmerzen.
Ja.
Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen genau?
Ja, die sind so am Bauchnabel und ein bisschen rechts davon.
Ja, rechts vom Bauchnabel und so ein bisschen unterhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Okay.
Waren die Schmerzen immer da?
Oder sind die Schmerzen gewandert?
Nee, die waren eigentlich von Anfang an in dieser Gegend.
In dieser Region.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Frau Nosbusch.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam?
Ja, ich habe es schon gemacht.
Ich habe es schon gemacht.
Und die sind plötzlich aufgetreten oder eher langsam?
Nein, die sind eher langsam aufgetreten.
Aber dann wurden sie ziemlich stark.
Ja.
Jetzt sind Sie stark geworden.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
6 bis 7.
Okay.
Frau Nosbusch, haben Sie etwas, was diese Schmerzen hindert oder verstärkt?
Also ich darf mich nicht auf den Bauch legen.
Das tut mir noch mehr weh, wenn ich auf dem Bauch liege.
Aber sonst liege ich meistens auf dem Sofa und habe die Knie etwas angezogen.
Das geht am besten.
Ich habe mich auf den Bauch liegen lassen.
Ich habe die Knie etwas angezogen.
Das geht am besten.
Wenn Sie Ihre Knie beugen, sind die Schmerzen besser.
Ja, besser.
Okay.
Frau Nosbusch, könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen etwas genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie dumpf, drücken, stechen oder kolikartig?
Nee, kolikartig nicht.
Sie sind eher dumpf.
Manchmal vielleicht etwas stechend, aber hauptsächlich dumpf.
Hauptsächlich dumpf.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie manchmal weg?
Nee, Sie sind meist immer da.
Okay.
Haben Sie gegen Ihre Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Aber ich habe gesagt, jetzt muss ich heute mal zu Ihnen kommen,
weil ich mich gut fühle.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut entschieden.
Frau Nosbusch, hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerde, ähnliche Schmerzen
oder ist es erstes Mal?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Nosbusch.
Wann waren Sie sonst letztes Mal auf die Toilette gegangen?
Das war vor, ja, gestern um diese Zeit, also vor einem Tag, vor 24 Stunden.
Mhm.
War das in Ordnung oder hatten Sie Durchfall?
Das war in Ordnung.
Kein Durchfall, keine Verstopfung.
Mhm. Okay.
Okay.
Ist das Ihnen ein Übel?
Ja, etwas Übel ist mir auch so ein bisschen in den letzten Stunden mehr.
Aber ich habe bisher nicht, aber ich habe keinen Erbrechen.
Sie haben noch nicht Erbrechen. Okay.
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Ja, jetzt die Schmerzen.
Ich habe heute Nacht da nicht gut geschlafen.
Ja, nicht so gut.
Also.
Ja, Frau Nosbusch, könnten Sie diese Schmerzen mehr aushalten bis unsere Gespräche so Ende ist?
Oder brauchen Sie unbedingt oder sofort ein Schmerzmittel?
Nein, das kann ich aushalten. Danke.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, das ist auch für unsere Unterhörer, für die kölkische Unterhörer besser.
Okay.
Werden Sie eine Einrichtung für die Vibe?
Nein.
Okay.
Hi.
habe ich bisher alles alles gut.
Alles gut, okay ja. Wie ist die Appetit, Frau Mussmusch?
Normalerweise ist mein Appetit ganz gut, aber seit gestern habe ich wenig gegessen, weil mir ja auch so ein bisschen übel ist und...
Ja, ich verstehe sie ganz gut.
Aber noch etwas Schüttelfrost.
Sie haben etwas Schüttelfrost, okay. Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe gemessen heute Morgen, habe ich im Mund gemessen und da war es 38,1.
38,1, okay. Sie haben im Mund gemessen.
Ja.
Okay. Frau Mussmusch, ist Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Ich meine in den letzten Monaten.
Ob sich mein, das Gewicht verändert hat?
Ja, Gewicht verändert.
Nein, ich habe das Gewicht schon seit einigen Jahren so gehalten.
Okay, okay.
Ja.
Frau Mussmusch, ist es Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, nicht so richtig schwindelig, aber eben, wir sind eben so ein bisschen übel und ja, aber schwindelig nicht.
Okay, okay. Ja, Frau Mussmusch, wann waren Sie letzte Monatsblutung?
Das war vor sechs Wochen.
Vor sechs Wochen. Könnte es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Das kann sein.
Das kann sein. Okay, ja. Ich werde das auch kontrollieren.
Verholtet Sie oder wie verholtet Sie?
Normalerweise nehme ich die Pille, aber seit einem halben Jahr nehme ich die Pille nicht.
Haben Sie Kindermusch?
Deswegen nehmen Sie keine Pille oder?
Ja, aber ich habe bisher keine Kinder.
Okay, okay.
Ich hoffe für Sie alles gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie normalerweise solche Verspätung mit Ihrer Periode oder ist das erste Mal?
Normalerweise ist die Periode regelmäßig.
Normalerweise regelmäßig. Okay, ja.
Okay, Frau Mussmusch.
Ja.
Wann waren Sie zum letzten Mal beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, als ich damals die Pille abgesetzt habe, vor einem halben Jahr.
Vor einem halben Jahr.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ja, da war nichts Auffälliges. Die Gynäkologin war zufrieden.
Okay, okay, ja.
Okay, Frau Mussmusch.
Jetzt würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorerkrankung stellen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche krönlich erkrankten zum Beispiel Schilddrösenprobleme
oder Suckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich nehme ein Schilddrösenmedikament,
weil ich eine etwas vergrößerte Schilddröse habe und da ist auch ein Knoten drin.
Und das wird aber einmal im Jahr kontrolliert.
Und mit Blutuntersuchungen.
Und sich jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht mehr groß was verändert.
Und der Arzt sagt, das kann ich erst mal so belassen.
Aber ich muss jeden Tag ein Medikament nehmen.
Welchen Medikament nehmen Sie?
Das ist Ältiroxin 75.
Ältiroxin 75.
Okay, einmal, wenn du das siehst.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe etwas Heuschnupfen.
Da muss ich manchmal, weil ich auch Sport mache, ich jogge.
Und ich spiele Handball.
Und dann muss ich manchmal, aber das ist nicht oft im Frühjahr,
muss ich etwas Astmas brei nehmen.
Damit ich Luftträge beim Sport.
Okay, aber besonders im Frühling.
Ja, das ist so meist im Mai, sind das so vier Wochen.
Und dann ist das aber auch vorbei.
Okay, wissen Sie, welches Spray Sie benutzen?
Das Spray heißt Sultanul.
Sultanul?
Ja.
Sultanul, okay.
Wie viele Milligramm oder Dosis?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay, benutzen Sie bei Bedarf im Frühling besonders, ja?
Ja, aber nur im Frühling, sonst nie.
Sonst nicht.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, wie hat Ihr Heuschnupfen bei Ihnen?
Haben Sie auch, ich gerade atmen noch?
Ja, ich habe dann die Nase läuft und manchmal brennen die Augen etwas.
Und wie gesagt, wenn ich dann Sport machen möchte,
dann nehme ich dieses Spray vorher, weil ich sonst kann ich nicht gut shoppen.
Okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Ja, Franz-Mussbursch, mussten Sie im Krankenhaus behandelt werden
oder hatten Sie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich war bisher sonst noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Okay, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Alargen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Okay, Franz-Mussbursch, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, das kontrolliert mein Hausarzt immer,
wenn ich zur Gesundheitsuntersuchung gehe.
Das ist alles in Ordnung für, er sagt immer, das ist für Europa in Ordnung.
Wenn ich irgendwo eine Fernreise machen wollte,
dann müsste ich mich noch breitere Impfungen machen lassen.
Aber das habe ich nicht vor, jetzt viermal gegen Corona geimpft.
Okay, ja, sehr gut.
Okay.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Elteroxin für ein 70-Mikrogramm und buy better Sultanol Spray.
Ja, ja.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente, regelmäßig oder buy better?
Nein.
Okay.
Okay, ja.
Franz-Mussbursch, jetzt würde ich ein paar Fragen so ihr erlebenst gewonnen haben.
Ja.
Raten Sie?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, noch nie.
Okay, sehr schön.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Drogen nehmen.
Hab ich recht?
Sie haben recht.
Okay.
Sie jucken regelmäßig oder treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich jucken dreimal in der Woche.
Oh, sehr schön.
Ich habe ungefähr eine Stunde.
Okay, ja, Sie sind sportlich aktiv.
Okay, Franz-Mussbursch.
Haben Ihre Elterngeswerte Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder...
Ja, mein Vater, der ist 60 Jahre alt und der hat etwas hohen Blutdruck.
Er muss da, glaube ich, zwei Tabletten nehmen, aber ich weiß nicht, welche,
aber er sagt, der ist damit gut eingestellt.
Dann hat mein Vater etwas mehr Asthma.
Da muss er auch einen Sprech nehmen, aber regelmäßig.
Das ist auch Ihr Vater, ja?
Ja, mein Vater, ja.
Und er hat eine Arthrose an der linken Hüfte.
Okay.
Die muss wohl bald operiert werden, so in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren hat der Arzt gesagt,
so muss die operieren.
Okay, okay, ja.
Ja, hat Ihre Mutter irgendeine Perche Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter, die hat, wie Sie immer gesagt, Gelenkrömer.
Ja, aber das ist kein entzündliches Gelenkrömer, aber sie hat ziemlich viele Arthrosen auch,
in den Fingern, im Knie.
Und darunter hat sie mit Zutonen.
Okay, okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Ja, haben Sie die Schwester, Frau Nussbüsch?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 32 Jahre alt, der hat auch Keuchchnupfen
und auch teilweise mit Asthma oder Asthmabeschwerden, so wie ich,
meist in dieser Zeit, so im Mai.
Aber sonst ist er gesund.
Okay, ja, okay.
Ja, Frau Nussbüsch, haben Sie keine Kinder, Sie haben schon das?
Nein, ich habe bisher keine Kinder.
Okay, leben Sie allein oder?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet und lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Frau Nussbüsch?
Ich bin Sozialarbeiterin und arbeite in einer Einrichtung für Jugendliche.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Nussbüsch, ich glaube, ich habe alle erforderliche Fragen von meiner Seite gestellt.
Ja.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, meine Frage ist natürlich, woran denken Sie, was kann ich haben,
was machen Sie, deshalb habe ich diese Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Frau Nussbüsch, Ihre Schmerzen können von verschiedenen Gründen haben,
dass eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Schwangerschaft bedingt,
das Problem kann sein.
Ja.
Deswegen werde ich das kontrollieren, ob Sie Schwanger sind.
Und noch eine Verdachtsdiagnose habe ich, das kann auch eine Appendicitis sein.
Was ist Appendicitis?
Appendicitis, was ist das?
Appendicitis ist eine Belinterm Entzündung.
Ach so, Interm.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, deswegen werde ich Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen und dann eine Bauchsonographie,
Bauchultraschallerde durchführen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und ich werde auch Blut abnehmen.
Dann sehen wir die Untersuchungsbefunde und können wir wieder sprechen.
Gut, können wir so machen.
Gut.
Vielen Dank für Ihr Geduld.
Jetzt bitte nehmen Sie Platz auf der Untersuchungsliege.
Ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Haben noch Kollegen Fragen?
Ja, haben Sie auf dem Scheider?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, danke schön.
Noch eine, haben Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, dumpf und etwas stechend.
Ich habe gesagt, glaube ich so, du ein dumpf auf den März,
manchmal etwas stechend, aber eher dumpf.
Vorab gefragt?
Ja, kein Opie hat die Patient.
Hab ich es ja noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Lesst denn 24 Stunden, haben Sie,
gehen Sie einmal,
verlettet oder gehen Sie Wind ab?
Aber also Stuhlgang, mein letzter Stuhlgang war ungefähr vor 24 Stunden.
Und?
Und Wasser lassen, habe ich gemacht, das geht.
Und da war nichts Auffälliges.
Also auch Wind geht ab.
Okay.
Okay. Gibt es bestimmte Haustürsäge?
Gefragt diese Fragen?
Nein.
Ich habe gesagt, ich kann nicht gut auf dem Bauch liegen.
Das tut mir sehr weh. Das mache ich nicht.
Ich lege die Lieber aufs Sofa, auf den Rücken und ziehe den Knie etwas an.
Nein, erst mal abhängig davon, ob sie nach der Nachlungs-
Ich habe aber eine Idee.
Seitdem ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, habe ich auch nicht so einen guten Appetit.
Da habe ich dann wenig gegessen.
Ich habe Hauptsache etwas Tee getrunken und etwas Wasser.
Einmal Schwangesch.
Nein.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt.
Waren Sie schon einmal Schwangesch?
Nein. Noch nie.
Ich möchte das Schwangesch.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich würde gerne das Schwangesch.
Nein.
Noch nie.
Ich war noch nie im Krankenhaus.
Ich bin nicht operiert worden.
Danke schön.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ich hoffe.
Okay, ich bin fertig.
Guten Abend, normal.
Ich möchte Ihnen unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Frau Anna-Lena Nusbus ist 29 Jahre alt.
Die Patientin ist 4,18 kg und 1,73 m groß.
Die Patientin stellt sich heute bei uns.
Regen seit zwei Tagen bestehende Abdominal-
Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen seien im Nabelsbereich und unteren Rechten-
Abdominalbereich.
Die Schmerzen seien auf einer Schmerz-
Skala von 1 bis 10 auf 7.
Und die Schmerz-
Charakter sei dumpf und stechen.
Die Patientin habe ähnliche Beschwerden nie gehabt.
Letzte Stülgang sei genau vor einem Tag.
Und es war unauffällig.
Wenn die Patientin auf der Bauch-
Liege lindere Dschmerzen,
lasse die Schmerzen nach.
Entschuldigung, verstärken sich die Schmerzen.
Und beim Knieborgeln lassen die Schmerzen nach.
Und beim Rückenlagen.
Lasst die Schmerzen nach.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei bis auf Fieber.
Und inapetens, unauffällig.
Die Patientin, die Monat-
von der Patientin sei vor 6 Jahren gewesen.
Früher habe die Patientin kontrastriktiver
Eingenommen aber vor 6 Jahren.
Die Patientin, die cose, die kontrastriktiver
abgestattet, wegen Kindergummen.
Wir haben eine Schwangerchaft gehabt.
Anfolger krankung,
eine Schilderösung,
Hypofunktion
Und Horschung und allergische Rene.
Die Patienten nannte eine schilddrösen Vergrößerung mit Knoten.
Eine Schumannodosa.
Schumannodosa, okay.
Schumannodosa.
Okay, ja.
Und sie nehmen
für 70 Mikrogramm,
elektroxene, regelmäßig ein.
Sie benutze besonders in Führung und bei Bedarf
Sultanol Spray.
Beide Patienten
sei
beide Patienten
ja, sei keine Operation durchgeführt worden.
Sie sei vollständig geimpft.
Ja, die Patienten
verrahen nicht und konsumieren keinen Alkohol.
Drogenkonsum auch wurde verneint.
Sie treiben dreimal
Progokspot. Sie gehen regelmäßig joggen.
Ja, die Familienanwemnisse ergab.
Eine arterielle Hypertonin, Asthma
und linkseitige Kokosartrose bei Fatem
und osteoarthritis,
ich glaube osteoarthritis bei demutam.
Ja, oder wahrscheinlich Polyarthrose
Polyarthrose bei demutam.
Wahrscheinlich Polyarthrose bei demutam.
Und der Bruder leide auch
an Hochenupfen und allergeschiss Asthma.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtstiagnose ist extra utterin Gradität.
Und als Deprensialdiagnose kommen
eine Appellatitis
und eine Ovarian-Torsion
oder Ovarian-Sistruktur
kann kommen in Frage.
Okay.
Bin ich mit einverstanden?
Vorgeschichte lässt daran denken,
die letzte Menz ist vor sechs Wochen
im Kinderwunsch,
dass es sich um eine extrauterin Gradität handeln kann.
Appendicitis kommt natürlich im Betrag,
eventuell auch eine entzündliche Damerkrankung.
Entzündliche Damerkrankung, ja.
Wannte man eventuell auch
mit in Erwägung ziehen.
Aber ich glaube, die wichtigste Differentialdiagnose
ist die Appendicitis.
Ja.
Ja, gut.
Ich finde, das haben Sie sehr systematisch
und ruhig
hergeleitet die Anamnese
und auch relativ zielsicher gefragt
und sind vielleicht dann auch relativ schnell
auf die Rächene gekommen,
wie ich auch unterstütze.
Denken Sie bitte daran,
die Fachbegriffe einzusetzen,
wie bei der Schilddröse eben,
nicht jetzt sagen Schilddrösen unter Funktionen,
sondern ich habe gesagt,
ich habe eine Schilddrösen-Vorgrößerung mit einem Knoten.
Und dann wollten Sie schon versuchen,
zu sagen Stroma-Nodosa.
Ja, das muss ich sagen,
die regelmäßig kontrolliert wird,
um einfach diese medizinischen Fachbegriffe
auch anzuwenden bei der Oberarztvorstellung.
Aber ansonsten haben Sie, denke ich,
die Fachbegriffe gut eingesetzt
und haben das für meinen Brüfe sehr gut gemacht.
Danke.
Wissen Sie sich noch prüfen lassen?
Man ist die Prüfung?
19. Dezember.
Ja.
Ja, eine Termin.
Da habe ich ein gutes Gefühl.
Danke. Vielen Dank.